the prime minister of the republic of
finland sana marine
[Applause]
good morning
dear colleagues
our sitting is resumed
the next item on the agenda is uh this
is europe debate
with the prime minister of finland sana
marin
dear colleagues today we have with us
dear prime minister thank you dear sanne
for accepting our invitation to address
the parliament and the people of europe
as part of our this is europe
series of debates
the world around us is changing faster
than many thoughts possible
many of us would never have
imagined that europe would again
experience war
on its doorstep
and on february 24th when president
putin's tanks rolled into independent
and sovereign ukraine
many of us would never have imagined
that russia's aggression would last over
200 days
the warning signs were there
we saw what happened in crimea
what they did to navalny
how they tried to crush democracy in
belarus
the targeted threats
against finland the eu country with the
longest border with russia
now it is time to respond
to stand up
to the values and for the values that
give europe it's sustainable advantage
and in doing so we must be ready to
adapt to the changing geopolitical
realities
right now people are worried about the
soaring prices of gas and electricity
there are things that we can do together
even temporarily to limit the impact
while we implement long-term strategies
we can no longer afford
to depend on undependable actors
and to face our real
shared security challenges
work must start immediately to build a
real security and defense union and here
i would like to welcome
finland's historic decision to join in
nato
we know finland has been a long time
nato partner and will be a key security
contributor in northern europe and in
the baltic sea area
the ramping up of efforts dear
colleagues will come at a cost but if
ever there was a moment for more europe
it is here and it is now
tomorrow
the european parliament here we will
host the president of the european
commission for the state of the european
union debate where we will have an
opportunity to speak
about these reforms
my hope is to see finland play a central
role in shaping the future of a more
resilient more united europe so dear
prime minister yes the floor is yours
madam president
distinguished members of the european
parliament europeans
my visit here at the european parliament
comes at a bleak hour europe is at war
with its aggression
towards ukraine russia has broken and
abandoned the key principles and
commitments of the european security
order
the
exceptional instability in the energy
markets and inflation are threatened
threatening europe with a downturn
the record high drought and natural
disasters say that climate change is
progressing and if we do not act
uh in time act now it will be too late
we will not get a second chance
but uh in the bleakest hours there are
there is still hope ukraine will win the
war with our support there are no other
alternatives in our hearts they have
already won
the ukrainians are courageous and they
do not give up
ukraine's counter-offensive is now
progressing unbelievably swiftly
russia has now been forced to retreat
from many areas
and together we have responded to
russia's aggression with
sanctions and by delivering ukraine
military financial and humanitarian aid
europe and the western world have been
very determined and
have shown great unity and unity is our
greatest strength here we need now more
unity than ever when russia is using
energy as a weapon towards europe
blackmailing our societies through
energy
supply is a way for russia to crumble
and and destroy europeans support to
ukraine and to destroy our unity and
putin must not be allowed to succeed in
this but but russia is using energy
to blackmail europe it is
operating very short-sightedly
and this ongoing energy crisis will mean
that europe will break free from russian
fossil energy even faster than was
thought and russia is destroying its own
economy and its own future our trust to
russia is gone and even though the the
war would end today our trust will not
be regained for a long time now but we
must show solidarity towards each other
we must look after our citizens we must
ensure that
we have energy available throughout
europe and we must be able to take
exceptional measures to lower the prices
of energy it is in these tough times
that the unity of europe is really
measured
our commitment to you to human rights to
rule of law and to democracy is now
measured russia thinks that our
our democracy our diversity and the
respect of human rights make us weak and
it is this dark doctrine that russia is
exporting but this is what makes us
strong our communities are flourishing
because in a democracy people can make
decisions for their own future and we
value diversity we promote human rights
we want to give everybody the chance to
succeed
dear parliamentarians it is an honor to
be here today speaking to you
the role of the european parliament as a
defender of our joint values is very
important at a time when these values
are challenged put to the test
and the european union is the most
important political framework of all of
its member states and after russia's
aggression we have proven that we can
act together
work together over and over again
and the unity of europe does not come
from above it comes from lively
democratic discussion and from an
understanding towards each other the
crisis of the past few years the
pandemic war and now the energy crisis
have shown that we need solidarity we
need unity because every member state
can need this in the in their turn and
that is why we need to foster our unity
because if the eu is internally divided
it is weak
and that is what russia wants
dear friends
we will be able to
tackle russia's extortion and the long
winter but we need unity determination
and courage to do that and when we
calculate the price of war in euros the
ukrainians are calculating it in human
lives
we are not just talking about
ukraine but we are talking about
european values and the entire
international rule-based system
members of the european parliament madam
president
the place of ukraine is in the european
union in june we showed integrity and
our trustworthiness as a partner when we
made new decisions as to the expansion
of the european union ukraine and
moldova were given the candidate country
status and georgia was given a european
perspective
and the convergence of the countries in
the west balkans is finally progressing
the road to becoming a member is not
short and the process will not be swift
but the european union's doors must be
open to all european countries that want
to be part of our value community and
are committed to making the necessary
reforms
we are talking about the country's own
willingness to decide for their own
futures and their place in the world we
are talking about the basic principle
that russia is now attacking against
the world of spheres of influence that
russia is now seeking cannot be approved
russia is challenging us blackmailing us
threatening us but we will not cave
as a result of russia's aggression
finland and sweden have now applied to
become members of nato and
the nato membership of our countries
will reinforce the security in the
entire northern europe and it will make
nato stronger
as a result of russia's actions the
western world is more united than ever
and russia is lonelier than ever
and first and foremost we must
continue our support to ukraine in all
of its forms and we must be ready to
take more sanctions
because the more impact we make with
sanctions the more expensive it will
become for russia to get to continue to
war
the sanctions must be reflected in the
everyday lives of ordinary russians it
is not right that while russia is
killing civilians in ukraine russian
tourists are free to travel in europe
we must limit the issuing of visas very
strongly
and the visa facilitation agreement
between the eu and russia
we must discontinue that it is a
well-founded decision but it is not
enough
madam president
energy availability and price will be
one of the key questions of the coming
months and years together we must do
everything we can so that ordinary
citizens and companies can survive the
coming fall and winter
in the short term it is necessary to
find all the ways that we can use to
secure the supply of energy and lower
energy prices it is important that
commission put forth
puts forth proposals that can be used to
decrease the price of electricity
to tackle the disturbances in the
electricity markets and acute questions
such as the electricity derivatives
exchange problems we
ordinary solutions are no longer enough
we need new bold solutions and it may be
necessary to take exceptional measures
in the medium and long term the only way
the only way we can come out of the
energy crisis is to invest very strongly
to renewable and emissions-free energy
production
common european transfer networks and
storage technologies we must break free
from russia russian fossil energy as
swiftly as possible energy investments
are necessary so that we can tackle the
climate crisis
even though the situation is far from
what we would hope and it will test all
european countries in an unprecedented
manner the crisis is also an opportunity
for a better future now at the latest we
must take the leap towards a more
climate resilient
economy the green transition investments
will make us more
more self-sufficient it they will
enforce reinforce our competitiveness
it is good
that the negotiations turn now turn to
their final stretch and we must ensure
that we maintain the level of ambition
of the fit for 55 package
honorable members of the parliament
the consequence of the war and energy
market crisis the european economy is
under enormous pressure at the same time
the expectations towards eu have further
increased it is clear that the european
union budget must be sufficiently robust
in order to
ensure the functional capacity also in
crisis a functional and internally
united union is credible also in
external relationships
still nevertheless
eu's development
of functional capacity does not happen
increasing the budget or slacking the
common euro economic rules
there is a lot that
we
must do together the union and the
member states the division of tasks
must be held clear in mind the economic
policy responsibility must
belong to the member states in the
futures well as
stated by the treaties and we have to
remember that our economies are not
separate ones but
when a recession hits one member states
the um the the consequences are felt in
the whole union the common rules are
needed and they have been further
developed the fiscal policy regulate a
regulatory framework
ensures
that member states don't get over
indebtedness
in that indebted and
that there is no such risk either
the common rules are not only about
financial policy but the common rules
have to be developed taken into account
also economic social and environmental
questions better than before
rules-based and responsible economic
policy must be
continued because only a responsible and
economic
economically robust community can also
help others like it does now
with ukraine honourable members of the
part the eu has shown its flexibility
and ability to act in crisis like now
also in exceptional times we will work
with determination to work for a better
europe promoting common goals and
realizing the previously agreed upon
reforms despite crisis tells about the
eu's ability to act
also under external pressure at the same
time the crisis have in a rough way also
revealed our vulnerabilities
the debate on the strategic autonomy is
one of the most important discussions
that are being carried out at the moment
it is the ability to face external
threats and to ensure the function in
our societies in
all situations
that is at stake when the pandemic swept
over us we were shaken to realize
just how dependent we are on extreme
print supply chains for medical devices
we had to rapidly build up our capacity
for ensuring the availability of
protective equipment and other equipment
and the war has shown us how important
it is that we have production of defense
material of our own and
how vulnerable we
are as far as energy is concerned we
must confess that we have adopted too
naive an attitude towards russia and
based our expectations on its
functioning on erroneous ideas we should
have better listen to our baltic and
polish friends who have lived under the
soviet rule
we are now paying a high price for
dependency on russian energy
the war and the price of energy
also threaten to
bring
a food crisis to the world
the europe has to have an appropriate
level of self-sufficiency as far as food
production is concerned and we have to
help others too
and
at its worst
the lack of
food can lead to famine
to social unrest and migration that is
why the african course is also our cause
even if we now concentrate on energy and
other acute questions and themes we must
prevent
future crisis too one of the crucial
questions will be our technological
knowledge and competence
our societies will be fully digitalized
in the future and we can't allow
ourselves to make the same mistakes that
we have made with energy we can't rely
on authoritarian states for developing
critical technologies or for supply
chains
we have to strengthen our
capacity to act with our democratic
party partners we can't afford being
naive it is not only an issue of economy
but also an issue of safety and
functionality of our society even if we
have challenges ahead of us i want to
underline that from the historical
perspective the european corporation is
a success story the fact that more and
more countries want to join our
democratic community proves this
nevertheless europe is no monolith the
european integration is not stopping but
it's changing constantly we have to be
better braver and even more competent
than before
eu's capacity to function is a question
of political will
finland takes a constructive view on
developing the eu
we take seriously the citizens voice and
also the new proposals made by the
conference on the future of europe
opening the treaties in the middle of a
crisis is not pertinent nevertheless
our citizens did not really
ask for institutional changes but rather
reforms that give a response to the
great challenges of the mankind and to
their everyday concerns
these challenges can be responded to
already within the present present
framework for example by increasing the
number of qualified majority decisions
under the cfdp
members of the pure
european parliament europeans
this crisis is not our first nor will it
be our last crisis
and we have to rely
on our greatest strength which is our
mutual trust and unity in order to be
externally strong we have to take care
of our common values internally which
are the rule of law democracy and the
human rights
acting on these principles
we will be able to overcome also the
future crisis thank you
[Applause]
thank you
thank you prime minister marin thank you
for those clear words i will now
uh open the floor uh to the leaders of
the political group so we start on
behalf of the epp group paulo angel
dear president
dear prime minister sana marin
allow me very shortly to express in
portuguese my condolences to the british
people
movies
also on behalf of the epp group i'll say
it in portuguese i wanted to express
my deep
solidarity with the whole british people
for the death of queen elizabeth ii
the portuguese have always felt a deep
affection
for the queen and also it's the the with
the britain we have the oldest defensive
alliance in the world congratulating
finland
the finnish people
and you as their elected representative
on your decision to join nato
this is one of the most important
geopolitical accomplishments of the 21st
century
not only because
it reinforces feeling security
but also because it strengthens the
entire euro-atlantic community and our
collective security
each european here
gains by having feelings join nato
just as we did by having finland join
the european union
it is a step
that requires great courage by the
finnish people and that completes the
process of full reintegration of finland
with our community of origin and destiny
in fact europe would never be complete
without finland and its contribution
there is no european culture without
finnish culture
our diversity is much richer
for having in our linguistic heritage
and non-european language which truly
opens the origins or is our horizons of
europe
no one can imagine european literature
without the calivalla or without the
name of a noleno
european architecture would not be the
same without architectural and design
works of alvar alto
not to mention the constitutional and
democratic contribution of 1919 finnish
constitution
which influenced the way the powers of
the head of state president are shaped
in constitutions such as the austria
icelandic irish french of 58 portuguese
and the constitutions after the fall of
the wall such as the lithuanian romanian
polish or check
finland the land of southern lakes can
always count on our support on our
solidarity in every respect
in this moment of grave danger
with war raging in our continent
feeling must know
that 26 other european countries
and the broader aero atlanta community
stands with you
in nearly china any challenges that
putin's and kremlin's war may bring
and we know
that we can count on you for the same
because of finnish resolve
that was proved
many in many occasions across history
yes the 2007
we stand for ukraine and for ukrainian
path towards european union we stand for
the balkan six mountain member states
georgia and moldovan path to european
union
turning to my mother language nist
in this context of very difficult times
i would like to
ask you a few questions
we're seeing older new challenges in
europe
that are really being brought to the
fore by the new war that we face let's
start with energy we need to create a
genuine energy union what proposals and
what vision does finland have in this
sector
does finland support
the building of interconnectors across
europe in greece in the iberian
peninsula in italy to try and diversify
our energy sources
what importance would you give
to investment in renewables
and what role would you give to nuclear
energy in europe
looking at the economic situation
inflation is rising interest rates are
rising and there's a genuine risk of
recession
how can the european union help families
and companies
should there be a windfall tax on
extraordinary profits
what does finland think about reform
reforming the european union
what about the agricultural crisis
and food sovereignty of the eu
and finally
the finnish know this better than anyone
else this crisis is going to affect our
viewer defense
with finland entering nato this is one
of the biggest steps in geopolitical
terms at the beginning of the 21st
century what
role does finland see for the building a
european defensive system with a
standardized european defense industry
with a european pillar within nato how
do you see the uh transatlantic
relationship we know that ukraine above
all of us but also finland the baltics
poland slovakia hungary romania
all the european union and europe
as well the whole world
are leaving
very worrying and challenging times
but in dpp group we keep faith and hope
keep the belief in the european way of
life
because
we deeply trust
in the ancient wisdom of finnish people
and so together
with you we can say
hatake no texting
the necessity is the mother of invention
and siddharth
paolo thank you
i give the floor now to the group leader
of the snd group aracha garcia perez you
have the floor
graphics
thank you very much
what happened
okay it's not working
we have no english translation can you
hear the translation now
yes
yes we will start your clock from zero
prime minister
i was saying that from the very
beginning of your mandate and despite
the
challenges that we face such as the
pandemic and the war
you're still at the helm of finland
leading it in a stable and strong way
and you're doing it in a true european
spirit because you know that it's only
by
standing united and working together and
it's only by boosting solidarity that we
can lay down the uh brave and courageous
path to follow yes prime minister
because we need people and women who are
brave like you brave women who do not
shrink back who are not intimidated by
putin's threats and that with
determination or have
led their country to join nato
brave women that make sure that the
citizens of finland are safer and more
protected but it's more than that it's
also that nato members and eu members
are safer more protected
that are building and strengthening a
world order that is based on uh legality
human rights and peace it is brave women
like you that shape the future and that
go down in history and that people learn
about
thousands of ukrainian
ukrainian civilians have lost their
lives since that terrible 24th of
february millions have been displaced or
had to flee to neighboring countries
faced with
putin's atrocities the eu has taken
historic measures and
finland's support and your leadership
prime minister have been vital for this
and the more putin threatens the more
unity he'll come up against now he wants
to he's trying to divide us by cutting
off energy sources hoping that this
great social unrest uh
uh that there could be great social
unrest and that it will mean that people
lose trust in their institutions but
we're not going to allow him as you said
we cannot continue with business as
usual we have to change things and
changing the rules of the electricity
market is not enough no we have to
immediately halt speculation in the gas
market increase its transparency and
build the necessary infrastructure as
well as tax the exorbitant profits in
order to help those who are in most
difficulty because the best anti-putin
antidote and against the best antidote
against his anti-european allies in the
far right is to have a more cohesive and
democratic society that is resilient and
that can provide solutions we have to
make sure that we bolster our welfare
state
and we need to halt the poverty and
poverty and inequality in their tracks
because not only do we need urgent
measures we also have to make sure that
we move towards
the future as the treaties make clear
the eu is a union of shared values we
cannot allow organ and his anti-european
colleagues to use us as hostages so that
we can act on the world stage the time
has come to move towards a qmv system
when it comes to decision-making and you
yourself refer to this in your speech
prime minister and we welcome this prime
minister as social democrats we know
that the green and digital transitions
will only be possible if there is a
strong social dimension
this is the only way we can ensure that
there will uh that our population will
be prosperous yes and this is the only
way we can ensure equality yes that
includes gender equality a real equality
so
that women in politics are not expected
to do three times what men are because
as you know sana we are here to stay we
are here to forge our rights and to
decide on our lives and the lives of the
women and men of europe because this is
how they're going to be more women and
young women that are willing to shape
the future and this is how we want to
support the writing of this new page in
the progress of europe and humanity
thank you
thank you very much
ms garcia perez and now on behalf of the
renew europe group i invite elsie
catinen to take the flaw
thank you madam president
dear prime minister dear son thank you
for your excellent analysis on the
situation of europe
europe has gone through the covid crisis
to the
brutal war of aggression of russia and
we are still in a very tough situation
this winter the unity of europe will be
tested
so far kovid and war have made
europe
uh more unified finland and sweden are
on their way to nato which is the only
right solution here
the common defense of the eu is becoming
stronger but we need to
now focus on our energy and food
policies
we as decision makers must make swift
and practical decisions and communicate
the meaning of those decisions to all of
our citizens it is also important that
we avoid
the political polarization and the
creation of blocks in europe as best we
can
because the defending defending of our
values especially in the global arena
requires that we are united and
determined
us we europeans we should not step on
the mine set by putin it is clear that
the purpose of russia's aggression has
been to destroy the energy markets in
europe
and to try to break our ranks putin is
using hunger as his weapon as the food
production and exports from ukraine has
been made extremely difficult now more
than ever when we are facing an external
threat we need to be more
united because only with a united front
can we
live past these very trying times
strategic autonomy as the prime minister
mentioned is
the key priority also for the renew
europe group we must pay more attention
to energy security of supply and
critical raw materials so that we can be
an increase our self-sufficiency and
stability as decision makers we must
make sure that we increase european
energy production and
adapt to the
electricity markets in a way where the
gas price increasing gas price will not
mean increasing sky high electricity
bills for our citizens we at renew
europe want to focus
more on on diversified energy portfolio
we need bio gas
forest based energy wind powers solar
power nuclear power hydro power
geothermal heat and all other energy
forms are necessary so that we can break
free from russian fossil energy and i
hope that the
parliament and the european council can
take a very practical approach to this
in their voting especially we now need
sustainable biomass based energy forms
that can take us through this acute
energy crisis and can help us in
achieving our energy and climate goals
and sustainable forest management has a
key role in this equation we cannot
forget that
madam prime minister food security is
not a concern just for us europeans this
is exceptional drought and
forest fires
floods are problems that the entire
world now shares the eu must be
more active in the food markets in the
world and
this means that we need to secure our
home base first and by this i mean that
we must secure
european food production
and profitability and i would like to
ask the prime minister
what do you see as necessary in in in
tackling all this because if we do not
take our own responsibility in this then
famine and the migration due to that
will increase in the world we must take
care of everybody
madam president
unfortunately it is a fact that
in the midst of all of these prolonged
crisis europe is now taking on more and
more debt and the downside of that is
that our economic growth will suffer
even during these crisis we must be able
to look far away
and to the horizon to make sure that
future generations can pay the bills
that we are now accruing stabilizing the
economy
uh supporting the eu's strong internal
markets and promoting our trade
relations are the cornerstones when we
are building the strong future european
union thank you
kitas
i give the floor now uh to the culture
of the green group philip lambert
mr prime minister welcome
uh in the name of the european uh the
greens and european free alliance it's
really a pleasure to see you here
because your presence reminds us that
actually every national government
is also as part of the european council
as european responsibilities and it's
really important that indeed we keep
that spirit
that member states are absolutely
crucial to the advancement of the
european union many things that you said
were actually music to my ears and
i would say there's little to disagree
with you your country is certainly
better placed
to know the true nature of the russian
dictatorship and indeed your warnings
and those of many former uh soviet bloc
countries now member states of the
european union have been ignored
and too long indeed there's been
complacency i would say especially in
the biggest member states germany france
italy uh towards russia and now we are
paying the price for that and you were
right to pound it out
your affirmation of course that united
we stand stronger you know this is the
motto of my country
and indeed
this is the motto as well of the uh
european union i liked also very much
the fact that and coming from you it's
interesting
uh your insistence that yes fiscal rules
are needed but actually they need to
take into account the social and
environmental dimensions and that indeed
is also welcome and also from a prime
minister saying that we need to tackle
energy speculation
is good because as many people who still
assert that speculation is good for the
markets you know but we also know the
downsides uh and the extraction
possibilities that give this gives to
economic players having said this i
think uh real friends have the duty to
be frank to one another and i'd like
actually to confront uh key aspects of
your speech at least two of the key
aspects of your speech to the reality
of
policy making in finland and of course
the first is the green transition
finland oftentimes portrays itself as a
leader of the green transition and
indeed at the last climate conference in
glasgow
your country boasted about its ambition
to beat climate neutral by 2035 15 years
ahead of the european union
this ball plant turns out to be actually
a false promise indeed the massive
carbon sink provided by your country's
forests was supposed to be the
cornerstone the foundation of the plan
i say was because it turns out that in
reality the land sector including
forests of course now emits
more carbon than it absorbs so it's no
longer a carbon sink
due to harmful industrial forestry
practices disguised as sustainable
forestry management
but forests are not only vital to our
climate strategy
when properly managed they are also a
haven of biodiversity and there again i
cannot understand that your government
has actively worked against
every eu initiative to include the
preservation of biodiversity in forestry
legislation in agriculture policy
the other source of major disappointment
is your
government's decision to join the
so-called frugal coalition
at the height of the pandemic when
fiscal solidarity was most needed
your government rather than extending a
helping hand
stood in the way
sure you came around in the end but the
impression remains that for your
government and for many people in
finland every euro cent invested in our
common endeavors would actually be
better spent at home
let me recall you and you said it
yourself that all members of
to you and to all the members of what i
call the stingy coalition
are massive net beneficiaries of the
european integration project if only
because of membership of the single
market
and sooner or later even the frugals end
up needing the solidarity of others
both sweden and finland are now seeking
the security guarantees of their new
nato partners so my message is simple
membership of a club is not and can
never be a one-way streets
its benefits come hand in hand with
responsibilities and commitments so
prime minister marin
under your leadership i hope and i
believe that the finnish government will
come to realize that it is in finland's
best interest to actually be
not claimed to be
among the leaders of the green
revolution and that fiscal solidarity
between member states is not a waste of
money but a sun investment in our common
future
under your leadership and with the
finnish greens at your side miss prime
minister this can actually happen so
just do it thank you
thank you mr lambert
i give the floor now to laura sari on
behalf of the id group
[Music]
europe will be saved and europeans will
survive if we get rid of the eu in its
present form
there is a proverb
that goes good times create weak men and
women and these weak
men and women have created a shocking
culture of criminal gangs in sweden with
their irresponsible immigration policy
and they have no means to make sweden a
safe place again
i
wish to congratulate the swedish
democrats for their
excellent victory in the election if
only you had been listened to before and
not only now
unfortunately
finnish state enterprises have been
detached from their basic task that is
from ensuring the national security of
energy supply
to
a money machine
for companies managers because of
juniper the films will
suffer losses of billions of euros
and indebted and poor finland will have
to pay the germany pay german the
germans electricity bills i don't
understand why finnish prime minister
was not in german to negotiate and
defend the finns
instead he preferred to go to a festival
the security of supply should be kept in
the domestic hands slovakia may
nationalize its main electricity
producer
slovakia wants to offer its citizens
affordable energy
stable
and affordable energy is a sign a
guarantee of prosperity and peace
that has made
it possible for the western civilization
to be born
europe was able to give its citizens and
its companies
a predictable and stable environment
this it can do no longer green
technology is not at a point in which we
could
use it to
substitute the fossil fuels
not at least without
an
important
decrease
in the living standards
europe has become poor inflation is
soaring china has almost no inflation
europe buys
russian expensive lng from china in 2024
we'll
probably see a greater regression
than depression than we can even see now
and that will create a chaos and after
that anything can happen
and at least one change has happened
already in the media field and in the
politics already our green minister
is for building a
a uh wall and the finnish broadca
casting company is not saying anymore
that finland is for all there are no
there are no fin finns
this change happened already
after russia
uh
invaded ukraine italian
banks
are falling and the losses
are being socialized again with an
instrument like a recovery plant
thatcher
at the end of her career said about the
eu that we did not fight against
communism in order to create a new
multinational
totalitarianism we have tough times
ahead of us maybe
sometimes we have to have really tough
times so that we could have better times
we should have common sense and national
states
uh there again thank you
dear colleagues perhaps we should tell
this secret to everyone
that politicians are normal people
they use the bathroom
like everyone else
they get sad or scared when something
happens
they make love even when they are not
french
this is how they too
make kids
we are just
normal people
not robots
but some people pretend not to know this
especially when it is about women
who runs the world you would ask
not girls not yet
there is still a long long way to go and
the price is high because they have no
right to make mistakes or simply to live
as a young woman in their private life
they are over scrutinized and pushed to
transform into something between a man
and a woman
just because you want to serve
some women give up
at times i also considered giving up
but every time you give up you abandon a
future a future where girls and boys can
be equal truly equal
and you abandon the possibility
to shape that world
you contribute to to shape a world where
sexism and patronizing remain the norm
things like
your skirt
is too short
your decollete is too deep or not enough
your smile is too bright smile oh no
don't smile
be a woman but not too much
what kind of mother are you actually
oh you have an opinion
perhaps you should be less ambitious
or
there is only a care for two men why
don't you take a sofa when you go to
ankara
it's not a place to be as a politician
when people are laughing at you it was
getting really dangerous for her career
said a former senior politician on bbc
about this young lady here because she
is prime minister
and also like students
this is europe not afghanistan
a place where men and women are equal in
theory but in reality equality is not
yet accomplished the truth is and it has
also been my experience that in europe
too in europe too too many women are
still not equal to men in politics you
feel it in meeting rooms you notice it
during debates
if you complain they say you are too
sensitive
you should toughen up
change a little bit who you are as if
being you was not enough
as a young politician when i was running
the first time i was told by some men to
ditch the campaign pictures where i was
smiling
and wearing a dress and show more
serious face
switch to suits
i struggled in front of my closet
whereas i should have been dealing with
files instead
and smiling as much as i wanted because
i like doing that and that is just light
coming from the inside
but one size fits all
maybe you want to dress like merkel or
clinton
or perhaps
you want to be like georgia maloney or
like alexandria ocasio-cortez
maybe their style is what you fancy
whether you agree with their views or
not these are face women who have kept
going even when their positions were
made impossible or too difficult
like some of them
i love dresses and nice shoes
does this make me a bad politician
i also love books
and dancing bare feet among my voters
and flanders while sharing a beer
or spending a night in my office over
files i care about
what else should make me a politician
this is europe dear friends the place
where women should be able to lead a
country into nato and have fun too
you do not need to become someone else
being human
is more than enough
we need you
to keep your head up
prime minister marine
show younger girls that politics is also
a place for them a place where they can
be themselves and work on serious topics
like energy climate security and so on
so you are not alone
by trying to destabilize you
they have made you an icon thank you to
admire
thank you asita
i give the flow now to sylvia moody on
behalf of the left group
madam president
madam prime minister
through the through the european
parliament and through your government
we have gone through many crises we have
we have must tackle these crises at the
same time and these crises are
threatening the basis of our existence
and the crisis are no long no are not
over yet covet is still there
and we must repair the damage for a long
time now and the pademic hit those
that already had it very hard and the
pandemic hit
women's sectors
especially hard
climate change is an existential threat
to to humanity
energy prices are now going up and we
are
blaming climate action for that but that
is not true the high prices are due to
russia's aggression
russia is using energy as a weapon in
this war
if or had we moved faster with the green
transition as the left has proposed for
years we would not have been so
dependent on russian fuel as we now are
we should have done more earlier
we would not be as as vulnerable as we
are now and at the same time when we are
breaking free from russian fossil energy
we must understand that we must also
break free from all fossil energy
anti-war activity they
they are not
contradicting our climate actions we
must focus on emissions-free
sustainable energy
only through that can we become
self-sufficient we cannot be dependent
on
authoritarian countries in that respect
anymore and these
operations can have a strong synergy and
i think we can all win here when the
prices are as high
households must really
tighten their belts so that they can
survive but we need systemic changes so
that societies and the structures of our
economies and our way of life can become
sustainable climate friendly and the
longer
we take in doing that doing that the
more expensive it will become and we
cannot
create a burden on this for for the
future generations
democracy is in a crisis as well
democracy is now fighting
autocratic regimes all over the world
and in the eu we have countries who are
threatening rule of law rule of law that
is the common value we have in the
european union
but we also must have a shared
understanding on how important rule of
law is rule of law and a legal society
they are the cornerstones of a free
society and those are the things that we
must defend with all means possible also
with economic sanctions
prime minister marin
you often talk about a vision
of a strategic autonomy
we support that very strongly thank you
kidas
i give the floor now on behalf of the
non-attached members to any kargieri
minister anna
dear prime minister
the scandinavians
such as uh famous for pragmatism
that's something lacking in current eu
policy so i would just ask you to become
a partner for a stronger
union so that we can address the most
pressing problems of european citizens
looking at the latest euro barometer
survey half of europeans take the view
that the eu
economy is going the wrong way
uh the cost of living is shooting up
and there is a risk of disruption to
energy supplies so we must come up with
a clear solution
firstly we must prevent the union
economy uh being
uh ruined
and the awful aggression of russia
must not be allowed to drag us into the
abyss we're all feeling the fallout
from these sanctions uh policy if we
keep
doing this recession will go up and so
will joblessness the figures are clear
the sanctions against russia are hitting
us more than the aggressor so we there
ought to be a complete change of
direction as to proposals to changing
energy policy these will need to to be
engaged
as to how they ensure security of supply
and the reduction of prices and we must
see
to it that the
that gas autonomy is taken account of
the proposal for a price cap
would undermine security of supply the
the
the proportion of russian gas in the eu
is nine percent
uh but
that's really focused on central europe
um countries which are
landlocked are
thereby worse off
the sanctions amount to a gas embargo
and that has to be decided by the
european uh council the third issue i
would want your collaboration on
is when it comes
to expelling
ideal
id the identity
that we need
to switch from nuclear
power enshrined in the green deal
families need to get the right kind of
help
and we're arguing about a lot of highly
politicized rules uh which will just
burden future generations uh with debt
let's pursue a more responsible
financial policy here
companies uh
including smes particularly
that must be
relieved
let's keep our feet
on the ground here
we should act in a culture of mutual
respect that our culture ought to be
restored please be a partner
uh for us who keeps a feet on the ground
we've had an
a debate about the rule of law
completely pointless let's put an end to
this
let's have transparency in the eu
the existing ideological uh the
differences should be kept out of any
negotiations uh this would meet hungary
would have access to what it requires
thank you very much uh miss geary and
now i give the flow back to you uh prime
minister marin to answer the questions
that you have received quite a wide
range of them go ahead
madam president
dear roberta dear friends
honorable parliamentarians i want to
thank you for your contributions today
your comments
also your critical comments they're all
very welcome
well i will answer to some of them first
of all i want to thank
all the member states from for the very
warm welcome and support that finland
and also sweden have
been uh enjoying through during our nato
process if there's something left of
this war for putin it's two more nato
countries in europe putin is going to
lose the war ukraine is going to win it
with our support and as a result of all
of this russia will be poorer and
finland and sweden members of the nato
the lamb lament
so a very warm thanks for this
in your contributions you talked a lot
about energy and this is very
understandable because
we we are in our third biggest crisis
within only a few years time energy is
our biggest challenge at the moment
it is now the biggest
challenge this autumn this coming winter
and in the coming years also
unfortunately this will not be sold
speedily this is our great big challenge
also in the future finland has been
making its own
energy
transition for over the years we are not
so much dependent on
for self use from russia we have
diversified our energy pilot in time we
have invested in renewable energy we
have also nuclear energy that we can
lean on to so we have a very varied
diverse
diversified energy portfolio but that we
are
self-sufficient and we have made these
decisions earlier it doesn't help
the whole of europe has to take these
decisions at the latest now that we need
in order to break free
as whole europe from fossil energy
sources we have to acknowledge i think
our mistakes as europe we have been
committing mistakes we have been relying
too much on russian energy it used to be
very cheap we have been building
our thinking
of russia on false premises we tied us
economically to others and such that
kind of war could be avoided because it
would become so expensive but that was a
false assumption we were wrong in our
thinking so we committed a mistake there
but we mustn't stay there we we have to
state the facts look in the future show
solidarity to one another and look for
solutions together what can we do
together how we can invest in renewable
energy faster
than before how we can create
energy grits in europe and support one
another so that the coming
autumn winter coming years are something
that we will make through them and it is
clear that one reason for our
problems is that we invest in renewable
energy or carry out green transition our
biggest problem is that we haven't been
doing this early enough we should have
done it
and carried out the change for climate
for environment to sustainable economy
much earlier then we wouldn't be in this
mess now
black made by russia
[Applause]
paolo ranger asked what we think about
windfall tax
financing that we could
channel to citizens finland takes a very
open stance here in our own national
decisions we have
started preparations to make possible
this windfall tax but here too of course
we need common european solutions they
are much more functional much more
reasonable and we support commission in
this work here
there were comments on secure
food crisis a very big concern to all of
us and as i said in
my introduction the african course is
also our course because if we cannot
make sure that uh we
in on top of our own citizens also about
the people in our neighborhood then we
will see
growing restlessness
violence maybe even wars will take place
and huge masses of
migratory flows so we have to be able to
prevent this together by helping our
friends in africa and elsewhere in the
world so yes europe very strongly has to
invest its own food production own
self-sufficiency in food production at
the same time
helping those who need our
support and aid
also
you were talking about european values
very clearly and i think we have to see
the reality where very bleakly we are
living now the war of aggression by
russia on ukraine is only one
facet of this
of the
fighting over values autocratic
countries
make their own policy
question
uh international
uh
multi-sided system
these countries do not respect human
rights they don't respect their own
citizens rights and they would like to
see europe and the rest of the west as a
weak part of the world so we're
struggling for our values and together
we have to make sure that democratic
values are going to win there is no
other alternative and the way we can do
this is to show our strength being
strong
strong supporting ukraine
strong when we
enhance our own capacities in europe we
cannot be naive
gullible we mustn't be weak so we have
to also ask ourselves
could we have avoided the war in ukraine
if eu had been stronger before should we
have been acting much stronger already
when russia
occupied crimea if we had been more
decisive then we would have been
stronger and
maybe then this war would not have
happened would russia then have thought
that it can attack a sovereign country
an independent country like it did
also questions about
finland's finland's
climate gold we want to be ambitious we
want to be climate neutral by
2035 we also want to enhance
nature diversity we want to make sure
that the environmental points of view
will be taken
into consideration in our politics and
be as an example for the rest of the
world well the reality is that finland
is one of the
most covered countries by forest in
europe
alongside with sweden we have a lot of
forestry that's important for our
industry and we think it is sustainable
industry and it is nationally a vital
question for us but i do want to believe
that at the same time it is possible
to make strong
climate policy secure nature diversity
and
builds
a strong economy and the finnish
government by its own actions wants to
show that by
working against climate change in favor
of nature and environment we can be
successful environment uh
internationally we can create new green
jobs and make take care of our own
citizens
so also this point of view that iracha
mentioned in her contribution
that is so-so dimension in the greens
and transition that is extremely
important
then at the end about equality
that was raised in many contributions i
also believe that if there is diversity
in decision taking different people from
different backgrounds men women younger
older
people from different walks of life
different social backgrounds highly
educated but also from working class
families
people taking part in decision making
then we will make our best decisions
together we need all of us on board to
make these decisions because we
even here in this room we are
representing all of the europeans we
need diversity also in our decision
making and i am very happy and pleased
that in finland
there's a government led by
five uh
women politicians and we have been
making very progressive politics at the
same time
we've been tackling this huge crisis
within which we are all living at the
moment but also we have
made very big reforms in the in the
finnish society to mention just a few a
historic family legislation so that both
fathers and mothers would take leave for
their families and children and we have
uh
the education age has been um
prolonged to make sure that our citizens
remain well educated we have been
tackling with the pandemic crisis
and we have had a huge reform on social
and health policy in finland
in finland we are not just women and
represent some gender in finland we also
make very hard political decisions like
any other
politician in this situation that is the
reason why we are here despite our
background age
or gender we all work for the benefit of
our citizens and when we have diversity
in
decision taken then also the decisions i
feel are better so thank you very much
for this opportunity to speak with you
today
and thank you for your speeches
[Applause]
thank you very much prime minister the
sitting is now suspended until we meet
again for the vote at 12.
you